JENNY MURPHY: Welcome to another
week of the Google+
platform office hours
on-air edition.
This week, we're going to be
talking a little bit about the
new configuration options
currently in Publisher Preview
for the Google+ badge, the
second in line of our social
plug-ins for Google+.
Before we dig in to that though,
let's do some quick
introductions.
And I'll start.
Hi.
I'm Jenny Murphy.
I'm a developer programs
engineer here on the Google+
platform developer relations
team, which means I spend a
lot of time getting kind of
down and dirty in the code
with you guys, whether it be
in forums, in office hours
like this, or in person
at events.
So.
JONATHAN BERI: Jonathan
Beri here.
I'm a developer advocate on
Google+, also working with
Jenny on developer relations.
You may have seen me speaking
at one of our many developer
events, GDD this past year or
upcoming ones like South by
Southwest.
FRASER CAIN: I'm Fraser Cain.
I'm the publisher of
Universe Today.
And we've been using Google+
quite a bit for doing our
weekly Space Hangout, live
recordings of Astronomy Cast
and our virtual star parties,
where people can see images of
telescopes all live streamed
onto Google+.
JENNY MURPHY: Cool.
FRASER CAIN: Among
other things.
JENNY MURPHY: You're
next, Allen.
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: I'm
Allen Firstenberg.
I'm a developer.
Most of my development work with
Google+ has mostly been
focused around the
Hangout API.
I've got a number of
different apps that
I'm working on there.
I also do some app development
work for Android.
JENNY MURPHY: And you're
next, Abraham.
ABRAHAM WILLIAMS: Hi.
I'm Abraham Williams. I'm a
front end developer and
developer community manager
at a YC combinator
company called InboxQ.
And I actually recently have
been working on a Chrome
extension that changes circles
in the Google+ UI to squares,
just for a little bit of fun.
JENNY MURPHY: Very cool.
JONATHAN BERI: Nice.
JENNY MURPHY: So a big part of
these hangouts is we answer
your questions live.
But before we do that, I'm going
to talk a little bit
about the new exciting Google+
badge features that are
currently in Publisher
Preview.
So I'm going to fire
up screen sharing.
And you should be seeing,
momentarily, the
reconfigurator for the
Google+ badge.
So before we dig in to the new
features we've added, I'm
going to tell you a little bit
about the Google+ badge
overall just in case you're
not familiar with it.
The badge, as you can see it
right here, this little white
box, is a way of connecting
your website to
your Google+ page.
You insert this social plug-in
onto your website, and then it
links back to your
Google+ page.
It also provides a single quick
way for people to add
your Google+ page to their
circles and easily follow you.
And it also encapsulates all
the capabilities of the +1
button, which includes sharing
and all that neat stuff.
It has some other side
benefits, like
Google Direct Connect.
But that's kind of a topic
that's beyond the scope of
this introduction.
But wait, there's more.
In response to a lot of feedback
we've gotten on the
badge, we've added some new
features which are currently
in Publisher Preview.
So I'm going to scroll down and
show you there's this new
Advanced Options panel that will
soon be available on the
Public Configuration tool.
And it exposes some neat things
to make the badge fit
better into your website.
The first and simplest
one is a dark layout.
So we click on the dark
layout button, and
the badge turns black.
So on your themes that are
darker and don't necessarily
have a white background,
the badge will
fit in a lot better.
And if this is one thing that's
been preventing you
from installing the badge,
it's a good time to start
investigating it.
There's one other cool
feature we've added.
A lot of people said that the
badge doesn't fit well on
their website.
So if you're the kind of person
who stays up at night
worrying about pixels, we
have a feature for you.
The default width
is still 300.
But we can go ahead and we
can change the width.
And the badge will live
update above.
And as you can see, the features
of the badge will
adjust to the size
you specify.
So if we go down to 170 pixels,
say we wanted to fit
it in our little sidebar on our
website, it shrinks down
to a pretty small size.
And all the other height
constraint features that were
available before are
still available.
So we can shrink the
badge even further.
So you can go anything from
the large 300 by 200 pixel
badge to the smaller 170 pixel
wide badge, which just shows
the following button, which
should give your users a great
experience.
So as I mentioned, these
features are currently in
Publisher Preview, which is an
open sign-up program if you'd
like to start experimenting with
the new features today.
I'll be adding a link to the
show notes when we're done.
This is this form, which you
can see I brought up now.
All you have to do is--
right there, and it will allow
you to add your account to the
preview group so that you'll
be able to see the new
features as we roll them out
a few days ahead into the
Publisher Preview group.
But even if you're not
interested in that, these
features will be available
very soon.
Preview group tends to
be pretty short.
And we roll the features out
pretty quickly after that.
So that's the new stuff
in the Google+ badge.
Hope you find it useful.
And here we are again.
You can see our lovely
faces again.
So now it's the part where we
start fielding your questions.
So before we take it any
further, do you have any
questions lined up, Jonathan?
Jonathan's going to be reading
the questions for us today,
and then the rest of us
will be fielding them.
JONATHAN BERI: Not yet.
JENNY MURPHY: Not yet.
JONATHAN BERI: Why don't you ask
the guys in the hangout?
JENNY MURPHY: Yeah.
How about you guys?
Have you guys been up to
anything cool or have any
questions about--?
FRASER CAIN: One question that I
noticed in the list was, how
do you make the video
size larger?
And that's sort of always the
first question that we get.
And so there's sort of two
ways to go about that.
One is that you can--
usually at this point someone
will have posted the raw video
feed into the comments.
And then you can get that,
you can click that.
And then you can press F11 and
then you get full screen.
The other thing you can do is
there's an extension called
Better Hangouts on Air.
And if you install that, then
you'll get a bunch of little
buttons right underneath
the video.
You can embed it.
You can maximize it.
And one of the things you can
do is pop the video out, and
you can expand it.
So if you're wondering how to do
that, it's Better Hangouts
on Air is the extension.
And it is always the first
question you get, is how do
you maximize it.
JENNY MURPHY: So that's
something we should add as a
built-in feature, perhaps.
FRASER CAIN: I would rec-- it
would save us all a lot of
time, yeah.
JENNY MURPHY: Cool.
FRASER CAIN: Yeah.
JENNY MURPHY: Anything
else coming in?
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: Do you want
to touch briefly on how the
badge relates to Direct Connect,
and how it relates to
the +1 button?
JENNY MURPHY: Sure.
So let me pull up the--
actually, I won't pull up
the screen sharing.
I'll just tell you about it.
So the badge actually contains
the +1 button, which provides
some additional functionality
that's kind of under the
covers, behind the scenes.
When you install the badge on
your site, it connects your
plus page to your website and
allows us to coalesce the +1s.
Which means that the +1s that
appear on the badge and your
Google+ page are actually
the union of the--
so it's the sum, only counting
the overlap once, of all the
+1s that happen on your web
page as well as those that
happen on your Google+ page,
which is pretty cool.
It also enables your website
to be available for Google
Direct Connect.
So what is Google
Direct Connect?
Let's take a look.
We'll fire up screen
sharing for this.
So you see a Google search
page up there.
Direct Connect, once we've
discovered that you have the
badge installed, the algorithm
will determine
[? when is the ?] time to
set up Direct Connect.
And once it has, you get these
cool shortcuts available.
So if you search for Plus
Android, we can see that
Android's Google+ page
is the first result.
And it gets a neat little
icon and stuff.
The plus sign is the indicator
that someone using Google
search is doing a Direct
Connect query.
When they click on that, some
special behavior opens up.
Rather than listing a search
result, it brings up their
Google+ page immediately.
And if I'm not following them
already, it will actually
prompt me to follow them.
So this is a great way, you
can just tell people, just
search for + my brand name.
So for my example site, + Baking
Disasters on Google.
And it will immediately bring up
your Google+ page, which is
pretty cool.
It's a great way to drive
people to that site.
JONATHAN BERI: So we
got a question.
Can I have a badge for my
Google+ profile, or does it
only work on pages?
JENNY MURPHY: That's
a great question.
Right now, the badge only works
on Google+ pages, which
are intended for non-person
entities, in general--
organizations, businesses,
or celebrities,
potentially, athletes--
which are people but they're
special because their page is
often managed by multiple
people.
But the badge does
not currently
work for profile pages.
But we've heard this a lot.
And we're trying to think
of how we want
to accomplish this.
FRASER CAIN: I've got one
question about this.
Is there any connection between
the badges and trying
to sort of make the
rel="author" tag more connected?
You know, the rel="author" for
identity on articles that you
write, to try and connect
that all together with
your Google+ profile.
Right now it's kind of hard
to implement on websites.
JENNY MURPHY: So the Google+
badge actually exposes a new
kind of semantic markup for
establishing relationships.
And it's the rel="publisher"
element.
So you do like a link
rel="publisher" and that's
actually how we determine that
your website is connected to
your Google+ page.
In terms of authorship itself,
although the story is still
kind of manifesting itself, the
authorship is definitely a
big part of the story.
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: [? Tamor ?]
asked a question on Fraser's
re-share of this.
He asks, can the Direct
Connect be enabled and
disabled on command?
JENNY MURPHY: So the Direct
Connect is kind of being done
on the back end.
We're crawling.
It's being done in the
search engine.
So it's being done
asynchronously.
For this reason, you can't
easily turn it on
or off at this time.
What you can do is, you can set
up the elements that will
allow us to know that you want
Direct Connect, which is the
rel="publisher" element.
And sign the Google badge.
And then you can remove those
elements, and tell us that
you're no longer interested.
But it is going to take some
time for that stuff to adjust,
just like a lot of stuff that
impacts search [? engines. ?]
JONATHAN BERI: Cool.
JENNY MURPHY: But that's
a great question.
JONATHAN BERI: So we had
one simple question.
Can you link to documentation
for the plug-ins badge?
And so I added that link
to the comments.
All of our documentation is at
developers.google.com/+ and
then you can find the
different areas.
We broke it down to plug-ins,
hangouts, APIs, and general
documentations.
JENNY MURPHY: We'll also be
including all of these links
in the show notes.
So if there's anything else
you'd like us to link,
definitely comment and we'll
be sure to add it.
FRASER CAIN: I don't know if you
guys noticed, Felicia Day
and Veronica Belmont broke
Google+ two days ago with
their hangout on Air.
They hit the 500
comment maximum
within about four minutes.
So I can definitely see that as
more and more celebrities
come on board and start
to do more of
these hangouts on Air--
that they passed up
to 500 literally
within like 20 minutes.
It didn't take them long.
JENNY MURPHY: Right.
That's a good point.
Us personally, doing the
platform office hours, we're
kind of investigating new ways
to have larger communities be
able to ask questions and
have those bubble up.
Although the comment stream is
very simple and accessible, it
has some limitations, like the
one you described of having a
500 comment limit on a post.
So in addition to expanding
the capability of the platform,
we're always looking
for other ways of making
this stuff easier.
JONATHAN BERI: Yeah.
Siegfried asks, can you
elaborate more on the privacy
policy that's needed when
your request more quota.
JENNY MURPHY: The privacy policy
that's needed when you
request more quota.
That's a good question.
JONATHAN BERI: So the short
answer is we're not lawyers.
And we can't provide
you legal advice
around the privacy policy.
But what we look for is a clear
expression of user data
in a privacy policy.
So for example, how you store
the data, how you access the
data, how you redistribute
that data.
As long as that--
this echo is killing me-- as
long as you include that in
the privacy policy and users can
discover that, we consider
that a good privacy policy.
In terms of the legal pieces
of a privacy policy, you'll
have to investigate that within
the country that you
live in and the country you wish
to operate the website.
JENNY MURPHY: Exactly.
JONATHAN BERI: That
was the short.
JENNY MURPHY: So hopefully
that's pretty straightforward.
But we can't offer you
any specific advice.
JONATHAN BERI: And if
I'm not hinting--
if I'm not expressing it well
enough, there's not a
clear-cut privacy policy.
We just want transparency.
OK.
So we have a few
more questions.
From Oleg, does the plus
name in search look at
the actual page name?
Or how does it determine
what to pull up?
Let's say there are 10
pages with Android 1,
Android 2, Android 3.
And there are badges linked to
them from various places.
So when someone searches for
plus Android, how does it
determine which plus
page to pull up?
JENNY MURPHY: That's
a great question.
This is something that's
a little bit fuzzy.
Because it's determined
algorithmically, but in
general it's the title of the
business page, the plus page.
So if you have that Android
page, it's going to be a +
Android, especially if
you're the official
Android page out there.
JONATHAN BERI: Cool.
This one's from Jeffrey.
Will putting a badge on a
business page help to verify
the business?
JENNY MURPHY: It certainly
can't hurt.
JONATHAN BERI: And the business
verification process
is part of the Geo team.
And there's a whole series of
policies of how to get your
business verified.
If you go to any one of the
business pages, there's a link
say, are you the owner?
And then you follow
that process.
They're not directly related,
but it just adds more
credibility to your business
if you have a plus page.
Greg prefaces his question, it
is not a badge question but
definitely a hangouts.
I sell G-apps for a biz, and I
have clients ask when Hangouts
On Air, especially with a
recording feature, will be
available in general
distribution?
JENNY MURPHY: As with many kind
of future-looking things,
this is something that's a
little difficult for us to
talk about.
Things are always changing.
We're always focusing
on what's most
important to our users.
And for this reason, the release
dates are not really
something we talk about.
Because we don't know
them ourselves.
Hangouts On Air, a wider
distribution is
one of these examples--
an example of this.
So we can't tell you when it'll
be available right now.
It's still really
experimental.
There are still a lot of
kinks to work out.
And we're still working with
our small set of testers to
make sure it's a really
accessible, great experience
for everyone before we
open it up wider.
JONATHAN BERI: Yeah.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
Next question from Robert is,
how do you limit the width of
a small badge?
JENNY MURPHY: Of
So currently, in the currently
production public version, you
can't limit the width
of the badge.
It is fixed at 300,
which is why we've
added these new features.
So I'm going to pop up
screen sharing again.
But in the version that's
currently on Publisher
Preview, which will be out very
soon, the width of the
small versus the large
badge is the same
configuration option.
So one width element,
specifically if you scroll
down to the code, we can see
that there's actually a width
attribute added to the G+ tag.
Which--let me zoom in--
so you can actually
see the code.
So down here in the little
code window on the
configuration tool,
you can see that
there's a width specifier.
Specifying that width attribute
is the same whether
you're using a small
or large badge.
In addition to the width
attribute being available,
we've actually added a height
attribute, which allows you to
specify the normal height and
the small badge height
explicitly in pixel size.
So it should be a little bit
more straightforward and open
us up to more possibilities
in the future.
JONATHAN BERI: Cool.
So Steven asks, can you take us
through the simplest way to
put the badge on our website.
JENNY MURPHY: Simplest way
to put the badge on
your website, sure.
I can definitely do that.
I'm going to have to fire
up an editor real quick.
Actually--
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: I'd also
point out while she is, that
if you're doing something like
a Wordpress site, a lot of
plug-ins are becoming available
that will add the
badge for you.
So there's not as much that
you'll need to do.
And it's suddenly occurred to me
that I haven't checked yet
if Blogger has gotten
a plug-in to do so.
And I'm looking now.
JENNY MURPHY: Cool.
So I don't have the set-up to
quickly do a live demo.
But I can show you the kind of
code walk-through process.
I'm going to fire up screen
sharing again, go back to our
window and I'm going
to zoom out.
So let's walk through setting
up the badge.
I'm going to reload this
configuration tool, which will
clear out all the options,
and walk you through the
steps to use it.
The first step is to go to the
configuration tool, which is
found on
developers.google.com/+.
You go into the left side menu
and you see a little
configuration tool option
in the menu.
And you click on it.
And it will bring you to this
configuration tool.
There's one manual step that
you're going to have to do to
enable the configuration tool,
which is get the ID of your
Google+ page.
So we're going to go over
to the other tab.
And we're going to go to my
wonderful Google+ page for
Baking Disasters, a fictional
business I
created for these demos.
And to get the Google+
page identifier, you
go up to the URL.
And you'll see a number
in there.
That number is the ID of
your Google+ page.
So we're going to copy that.
We're going to go over into
the configuration tool and
paste it in.
The badge will automatically
show up in the preview.
So the next step is to format
the badge using these tools to
make it look how you want--
the correct language, if
you're experimenting with the
preview for [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
version of badge, maybe
change the width--
until you end up with
a badge with the
configuration that you want.
And while I've been making all
these changes to the badge,
within the tool we
can scroll down.
And this code has been updating
in real time.
It's just been off the screen so
you weren't able to see it.
And in this code we see a
few different things.
The first thing we see is
a link element with a
rel="publisher" attribute.
We can get in a little
further.
The rel="publisher" attribute
and the URL
of our Google+ page.
This is the feature that tells
crawlers that hit your web
page about your Google+ page
and that you are the
owner of that page.
This is how the Direct Connect
feature is enabled.
This is also how the coalescing
of the +1 count is
identified and registered.
The next element in this little
snippet of code is some
JavaScript code.
It actually starts over here
but this is the meat of it.
And this element initializes the
JavaScript that knows how
to render the Google+ badge
as well as the +1 button.
It's actually the
same JavaScript.
And this also specifies some of
our configuration, like the
English language, some of the
stuff that's kind of global
throughout the page.
These two elements we will
grab and, just as it's
described in this comment up
here, we'll copy them and go
over to our fictional web page,
which is just in a pasty
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] right now.
And we just stick these things
right into the head of our
HTML document.
So the link will, as I said
before, allow Google to
identify that link between
your plus page
and your web page.
And this big chunk of JavaScript
will asynchronously
load the JavaScript that's
required to render the badge
in such a way that it doesn't
interfere with the loading of
the rest of your page.
So it won't slow
anything down.
But there's one more step.
We go back to the configuration
tool.
We notice there's one
more chunk of stuff.
There's the code that's actually
the badge itself.
So we place this tag just as
it's described, wherever we
want that badge to render.
So let's copy it and go
back to our pasty.
And let's pretend there's
content on this web page.
This web page is very
spartan right now,
contains nothing at all.
But let's say we wanted to put
it below our title and before
our content.
So when we render this page, it
will put the Google+ badge
below the title and above that
"content is awesome" content.
And that's it.
That's how easy it is to set
up the badge on your page.
And if you'd like to go a little
further-- let me scroll
up through this way zoomed
out web page--
there's actually documentation
that describes a whole bunch
of more configuration options,
and describes what all these
things do in detail.
I'm not going to go through
all them here.
But I will link to them
in the show notes.
And this shows you all the
different ways that you can
configure the badge and how you
can manually set it up.
For example, if you want to
change the way it loads or if
you have to integrate it
differently depending on how
your website renders.
Like you know, if you had
to put certain things in
different templates.
And it also shows you
some cool tricks.
So we'll be linking to those
in the show notes.
And that's how easy it
is to install the
badge on your web page.
JONATHAN BERI: Cool.
Siegfried has a follow-up
question regarding the privacy
policy, which I'm super excited
because I actually
want to clarify this
a little bit.
Are there any needs to offer
delete options if I save
public information about
the author [? after ?]
in the database?
There's a few places to learn
about our policies and our
terms of service.
And I encourage everybody's
who's building anything with
the API, even if you're just
using the badge, to review at
the very least the policy.
So to find the [? topic ?] of
the policy stuff, it's at
/+/policies on our
developers site.
Jenny, if you could just
pull those up.
JENNY MURPHY: Sure.
I'll screen share.
JONATHAN BERI: Because
it's worth noting.
If you look at this, this
doesn't look like your typical
legal document.
A lot of it's about spirit of
how we want users to be
treated with our APIs.
The first three bullet points
are the most important.
Put the user first, be
transparent, and
respect user data.
And that's the general theme
of the rest of the policies
and the terms of service, too.
And it's a more digestible
way.
You can read it probably by
the time I'm done talking.
There's a big section on
personal information from the
Google+ APIs.
And specifically to Siegfried's
question about
deletion, point three,
deletion rules.
We ask that as a developer you
give a user a reasonably
convenient way to delete any
of their personal data.
Does that have to be a true
export in deletion, like we
offer with Takeout?
No, that could be when they
disassociate their account,
you delete it.
Or some other way that they
know that their content's
being protected and wiped
from your system.
To go into the more legalese,
heavier definition of it, we
have a Google+ platform terms
of service, which is spartan
in comparison to our general
API terms of service.
And that actually goes into more
detail about our views of
data portability and how
we generally expect all
developers who use Google
platform to build upon to have
a concept of data portability.
What that means for your privacy
policy, to go back to
the original question, doesn't
have to be explicitly
expressed in that policy.
It would be great if you just
tell the users what you're
doing with their data, and
what happens when they
disassociate, how they
delete that.
But in general, you should be
taking care of that on the
users that you have. And it's
a great place to say that in
the privacy policy.
Another place, if you're
interested in data
portability, is to
actually having a
data portability policy.
And I believe
dataportability.org has
guidelines of how to express
data portability.
So awesome question.
Obviously one I am
passionate about.
Next question.
Can I use the API to write to
an activity or a chat pane?
It looks like it's read-only
at the moment.
Also, is the chatroom
stored permanently
after the hangout ends?
Seems like three questions.
JENNY MURPHY: So the
first question--
it sounds like you've actually
done your homework.
And you've researched the
API a little bit.
The RESTful web services that
make up the core of our API,
and the hangout apps, neither of
them expose the ability to
create activities in the stream,
nor to interact with
the chat window on a hangout.
The only way to create
activities in the stream right
now is with the social plug-ins,
the third component
of our platform--
the brand badge as well
as the +1 button.
The chats themselves in the
hangouts are not persistent.
So, in response to your
third question.
FRASER CAIN: Yeah, in general,
you gotta make sure that you
don't post anything into that
chat that you want to keep.
JONATHAN BERI: When will the
Hangout On Air, or just API,
be available for embedding on
a third party site, if ever?
So in terms of the Hangout
On Air, that's
actually an easy question.
It's a YouTube stream.
And if you've seen some of the
more public Hangout On Airs--
a few weekends ago, there
was an artist
doing body art painting--
it's just a YouTube
livestream event.
So you can actually grab the
embed widget and stick it on
any page you want.
If you noticed, some people
included the YouTube link, the
full-screen link, the extension
that was mentioned
earlier also does
that same thing.
So you can embed that.
In terms of the hangout
themselves,
currently no plans.
And the general future release
type of things that we don't
comment on, we've heard
ideas around that.
And we're looking into it.
But no timeline or any
promises around that.
FRASER CAIN: Yeah.
That's one of the things
that we're doing.
It's relatively straightforward.
So you can actually--
we're livestreaming our
Astronomy hangouts.
We've actually got a page that
you can go to that, as soon as
we start our event, we have a
little publisher section.
And we can put the embed
code in there.
And then it can stream
from that location.
We pull the comments from
Google+ as well as Twitter at
the same time.
And so it's sort of like a
single location you can go and
just kind of wait.
And then when the show starts,
then the screen updates.
So it's definitely, definitely
possible.
We've done it.
JENNY MURPHY: Yeah, that's
a very cool feature.
JONATHAN BERI: This one's a
feature request from Oleg.
Since we're talking about pages,
one feature I would
like to see getting added is a
Google Calendar link, or embed
on business pages as
a standard feature.
So there's actually two
features on here.
Cool.
JENNY MURPHY: Yeah.
We like those ideas.
We've heard some
of them before.
And I think they're--
or one of them, I've heard
the events link.
I think that's a really
cool idea.
And we'll relay it.
ABRAHAM WILLIAMS: I think
something that a number of
people are requesting
is a transparent
background on the badge.
JENNY MURPHY: So there are some
technical reasons that we
decided to have a white and a
black background for now.
It's that the badge is actually
rendering in a single iFrame.
And iFrames are opaque.
So there's some challenges
there.
But it's definitely feedback
we've heard.
We're considering it.
And we're looking for ways to
make sure that the badge fits
well into everyone's website.
So keep that feedback coming.
JONATHAN BERI: Rob asked, is
there any way to incorporate
the chatroom function for those
watching hangout instead
of the current stream comment.
I know that you can have a chat
within a hangout and you
can have participants, but
not just the viewers.
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: This
is a very, very
often requested feature.
If you speak to the hangout
people and the hangout people
have their own chat tomorrow
tonight or tomorrow afternoon,
and ask them, they will tell
you the same thing.
Everyone's requesting it.
They don't have a date yet for
when this will be in place.
JENNY MURPHY: Thank you
very much, Allen.
Yeah, that sums it
up pretty well.
We're definitely investigating a
lot of ways that we can have
people who are watching the
Hangout On Air interact with
the rest of the hangout.
Chats are some ideas.
There's a lot of different ideas
we're kicking around.
We just want to make sure that
whatever we launch works
really well for everyone.
And everyone has a really great
experience, whether they
be doing a Hangout On Air with
a smaller audience or an
enormous audience, where they
hit that 500 comment limit on
the post within ten minutes.
So we're working on stuff.
Hang tight.
JONATHAN BERI: As you can see,
we're experimenting with
different ways to run
our Hangouts On Air.
And we might decide that the
comment system works for us.
But somebody else might
find another way.
And then the product might
converge on a different one.
So it's cool to experiment
around how you use Google+.
And a lot of that time
that becomes the
next feature in Google+.
So definitely good if you can
submit that feedback.
And join the office
hours tomorrow.
JENNY MURPHY: And if you've
done any interesting
experiments, or anyone out
there, if you come up with a
really cool solution to this
challenge, please let us know.
Or you know, the hangout
office hours also.
We'd like to hear it.
We know that a lot of
the greatest ideas
come from the community.
JONATHAN BERI: So CJ asks, what
happens in the event the
user browses my web page,
observes the badge, but is not
signed into his or her
Google account.
JENNY MURPHY: So if the visitor
is not signed in to
their Google account, they
will see a badge this is
rendered as if they have not
added them to their circle,
because we don't know
who they are.
So [? it declares ?] the Add
to Circles button up there.
How much I can actually probably
show you-- let me get
that configuration
tool back up.
I'll show you what
it looks like.
So it's going to be a
very standard badge.
All right, screen
sharing again.
So it's going to look-- if
they're not signed in, it's
going to look a lot like this.
It'll have the Add to Circles
option up there.
It'll have the +1 button.
Neither of them will
be toggled.
Because we don't know who
that user is, because
they're not signed in.
The [? invitation's ?]
below, next to the +1 button.
Probably contain more general
information and less personal,
specific information.
When they click on either of the
buttons to trigger one of
these user specific events,
we're going to open up a
window that'll allow them to
sign in so they can complete
that action.
If they don't have a Google+
account and they've signed in,
then we'll take them through the
flow to allow them to sign
up for a Google+ account
pretty quickly.
So that they can get back to
your web page and do whatever
they were doing there.
JONATHAN BERI: Great question.
Yari, or Jari, asks, Google+
API question.
Right time.
It is not yet possible to get
all public posts from a
Google+ user with Google+ API.
There is some kind of limit
around 460 ports or something.
And then he links
to something--
to some service I
think he builds.
Do you know if there's plans
to remove this limit?
JENNY MURPHY: This
limit sounds like
a pretty big challenge.
This is the first I've
heard of it.
You should be able
to keep paging
through the public posts.
This is something I would
personally consider a
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
I'm going to dig in to it and
figure out what's going on.
Thanks for the link.
I'll follow up.
And we'll see if we can
get this fixed.
Because you should be able to
keep going back to those
public posts.
And you should be able
to access everything.
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: There used
to be a 250 post limit.
But that has been gone for
a couple of months now.
I am wondering if this is
related to a limit on the
number of API crawls within
a certain time frame.
I don't know his circumstances
of his question.
But that would be my first
debugging question.
JENNY MURPHY: It is true.
If you're hammering through
the APIs really quickly,
you're probably going to hit
some query-per-second limit of
your IP or something
like that.
But if you hit that, you should
be getting a pretty
clear message back in the
response body telling you
exactly what you're
doing wrong.
The tokens that you get back,
the paging tokens, should
persist for quite a while.
So you should definitely
be able to page
through all the results.
You may have to throttle
yourself if you're going
through an enormous number.
But 460 is only like, four
and a half pages at the
maximum page size.
So this shouldn't be
too challenging.
We'll follow up with
you on this one.
JONATHAN BERI: Gregory just has
a bug report on Firefox 9.
So I guess we'll follow
up with that.
JENNY MURPHY: Yeah.
Thank you very much.
JONATHAN BERI: Siegfried has
a separate question.
It says, the search feature
in API is getting better.
JENNY MURPHY: Yay.
JONATHAN BERI: Thanks,
awesome.
And finding more relevant and
up-to-date activities.
Will this get better over time,
or how can we measure
how good the results are?
Hmm.
JENNY MURPHY: This is something
we're constantly doing.
We like search here, as
you might expect.
So we're constantly working to
improve the search results
that you're seeing from
the API as well as
from the web interface.
And we're going to be
continually improving that.
And we're doing a lot of
measurements ourselves to see
how well we're doing.
And this is kind of the
stuff we don't really
talk about too much.
So I can't go into
any details.
But this is another
great question.
We're definitely working to
improve the search results.
And we're really glad that
you're noticing that they're
getting better.
That means we're on
the right track.
JONATHAN BERI: And in terms of
how can you measure how good
the results are?
If you're finding what
you're searching?
No, in all seriousness.
It definitely is something
we actively work on.
Not just the API team, but it's
more of the product team
and the search team that's
part of Google+.
And we're adding more data
points, and we're improving
our algorithms, and for
sure it's going to
get better over time.
That's one thing I
can guarantee.
[? Tamar ?] asks, where
can I find the notes?
JENNY MURPHY: Where can
you find the notes?
The official location, the
official write-up, is in the
Google+ Platform Discussion
Forum.
Fortunately, we're going to
be linking to that from
all over the place.
So if you can find this post
that you've commented on just
now, the video recording, once
it's been added in YouTube, or
any other posts that follow-up
about these office hours or
the event on Google developers
all these are going to link to
the canonical location where
all the show notes and all
those links are held.
So pretty much anywhere,
even the post you're
looking at right now.
Great question though.
JONATHAN BERI: So
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] asks, I have
a rel="publisher" link set up
in the profile about page
links back, but auto-complete
doesn't link to it.
I assume by auto-complete you
mean the Direct Connect.
JENNY MURPHY: Yeah, the plus
sign Direct Connect
auto-complete.
So that's one of those things
that happens asynchronously.
There's no way that you can
explicitly hit a button and
turn it on right now.
But by adding that
rel="publisher," you're
telling us that you want
to be involved in the
Direct Connect program.
So when the time comes around,
when the algorithm has decided
it's a good time, we're
going to add that plus
auto-complete thing.
JONATHAN BERI: [? Ellen ?] asks,
any other way to verify
that he's done everything
correct?
JENNY MURPHY: There is
not any specific way.
You can use the rich
snippet tool.
JONATHAN BERI: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
JENNY MURPHY: The rich snippet
tool will tell you if your
mark-up is correctly
[? well-formed. ?]
And that's going to be a good
indication that everything is
set up well.
But other than that, all you can
kind of do is hang out and
wait for it to get enabled.
JONATHAN BERI: So Robert asks,
when will the width and height
be available in the developer
config tool?
Is yours different
from mine now?
JENNY MURPHY: So mine is a
little different from yours.
And I'm actually going to show
you how you can play with it
right away.
So going back to that same
window I had been showing you
for a lot of the hangout,
there is a web page that
allows you to sign up for
the Platform Preview.
The Platform Preview gives you
slightly early access for your
account to see what some of
our future social plug-ins
will look like.
And the reason we have this
group in existence is so that
you, as the webmaster, can
adjust your website for the
new features of the badge.
So you can take advantage of new
features of the badge, the
+1 button, any of our other
social plug-ins, the moment
they're available.
It's pretty easy to
join this group.
It's linked from the
documentation for the brand
badge right now.
All you have to do when you get
on this page, which I'll
also include in the show notes,
is just go here and put
in your email address.
And when you put in your email
address and sign up, you'll be
added to the group.
Whenever we have a new
feature, like the new
configuration tool with the
width and height, entering
Platform Preview, we will send
you a notification so that you
know to go look at it
and play with it.
And it's just that simple.
JONATHAN BERI: Cool.
Lisa asks, any plans for
integration of any stream
access and publishing
with third party
dashboards like HootSuite?
JENNY MURPHY: That's
a great question.
We're actually experimenting
with that stuff right now in a
very limited scope.
And we're not really sure
exactly how that's going to
expand yet.
It's still in the
early stages.
But it is definitely something
we're actively working on.
And if you dig around, if you
Google around, you'll see that
HootSuite actually talked about
our partnership already
a little bit.
JONATHAN BERI: Yes.
I believe there's even a sign-up
page on the HootSuite
site to allow you to
request access.
So you can contact them for more
information about that.
Let's see.
There's a lot of requests for
IRC chat and different ways to
get chats and hangouts.
JENNY MURPHY: We actually
have an IRC channel.
But I don't think any of us
are in there right now.
But if you guys would like to
chat about it while we're
doing the Hangouts On Air or
anything else, we are on
Freenode at Google+ Platform.
And we will be adding--
we're still in the early
stages, we're still
experimenting with this
as a support channel.
But it sounds like people
are interested.
So go check it out.
And we'll be linking to it from
our documentation in the
near future.
So it'll be easier
for you to find.
But I hang out in there a lot.
So you can always find me
there, except right now.
Because I'm busy,
for some reason.
JONATHAN BERI: So we have--
so we're hitting about the
edge of our time frame.
Let's see.
There's some good comments and
suggestions of how to fix the
iFrame, transparency issue,
questions about what's
drawn behind us.
Those are actually Google+
dinosaurs.
JENNY MURPHY: Rahhh!
JONATHAN BERI: Not what
Oleg suggests.
Timing, when are Google+
office hours?
Same time.
We have office hours every week
at the same time, same
bad channel.
You can always find us in our
streams posting about it,
whoever gets to it first.
JENNY MURPHY: I also post
messages in the discussion
group a few days
ahead of time.
And there will be an event on
the Google developers event
list that you can use to RSVP.
And we update those as news
develops on them.
But they're always
at the same time.
11:30 AM Pacific time, which is
during the workday for most
of North America and the
Americas, and in the evening
and early night for most of
our European friends.
Or later night, I guess,
for a lot of you.
JONATHAN BERI: Let's see if
there's one more question.
JENNY MURPHY: Before
we wrap up, yeah.
JONATHAN BERI: And I guess
Nicholas's question is the
most important.
Can you work more and faster?
JENNY MURPHY: We work--
we really love our jobs.
So we work more and
fast a lot.
Like it's almost fast motion
here sometimes.
JONATHAN BERI: And so there's
a certain limit to how much
more you can do.
Because there's only 24
hours in a single day.
The best we can suggest
is if you just keep
the feedback coming.
Then we can be more efficient
with that,
with those 24 hours.
JENNY MURPHY: Yeah.
We always love the feedback.
JONATHAN BERI: And on that note,
I think that ends this
week's office hours.
JENNY MURPHY: Does anyone else
in the hangout have any--
JONATHAN BERI: --final words?
FRASER CAIN: I have one quick
comment, which was, did you
guys get a chance to catch
President Obama's hangout
couple of days ago?
JONATHAN BERI: Of course.
JENNY MURPHY: Yeah.
FRASER CAIN: It was a pretty
cool demonstration of what
hangouts could look like and
should look like, I think.
And in many cases,
it was awesome.
Because you could click, you
could maximize, it was
high-def, the audio
sounded good.
They were clearly able to
bring in like high-grade
cameras into the stream.
All of the pieces were there.
So if that's the technology road
map, I think all of us
working in this space can
definitely agree that that's
where it ought to go.
Because that was amazing.
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: Fraser,
have you seen Peter
McDermott's interviews
with some of the
participants of that?
FRASER CAIN: Yeah.
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: I encourage
anybody who hasn't to go find
those interviews.
Because some of them are very
interesting, very revealing.
And not just to see what the
participants thought of it,
but what they think of Google+
and hangouts now.
FRASER CAIN: Yeah.
I mean in many cases they had
never heard of Google+ or
didn't really understand the
hangouts, but they were
brought up to speed.
And pretty transformative in
going through the process.
But I think that as the way the
hangout ran and the way it
was as a communication
and publishing
channel was pretty great.
And so if you can sort of push
back to achieve that, please.
We want that, exactly that.
JENNY MURPHY: Yeah.
I think we all want that.
And we're definitely working
towards making this stuff as
good as we can.
And there's definitely some
stuff we use as kind of a
model for that.
Cool.
So unless there's anything else,
I think we're going to
call it a day.
ABRAHAM WILLIAMS: I actually
have a quick question.
Do you know the current
status of the--
so you can put the rel="author"
link to your
Google+ profile on your blog.
And then when those blog posts
show up in search results,
it'll embed your
profile image.
Are you aware of the
status of that?
JENNY MURPHY: That is the
authorship feature.
And that is available now.
So you can start
doing that now.
You can use tools like that rich
snippet testing tool to
validate that your markup
is correctly configured.
And in search results, a lot
of my search results I see
stuff that I've written showing
up with my profile
picture and links to information
about me there.
So it's already there.
ABRAHAM WILLIAMS:
Is it automatic?
Last I checked, there was some
submission form you had to
fill out to get in.
So is it all automatic
now, or--
JENNY MURPHY: There is a
submission form that will help
us prioritize.
But it's open right now.
We're actively crawling and
looking through that
information and using it
to create the best
search results we can.
ABRAHAM WILLIAMS: Awesome.
JENNY MURPHY: Yeah.
ABRAHAM WILLIAMS: Thank you.
JENNY MURPHY: Very, very
welcome, of course.
All right.
Unless there's anything else,
I think we're going
to call it a day.
Thanks to everyone out there,
everyone who joined us in the
hangout, and everyone out on
Google+ who asked some
wonderful questions.
And we will be seeing
you next week.
JONATHAN BERI: And don't
forget, if you have any
questions you didn't get a
chance to answer, you can ask
it in our forums, which is
linked from our developer site
as well as our Google+
profiles.
JENNY MURPHY: Yep.
So feel free to ping
us, anytime.
Thanks again.
Bye everybody.
JONATHAN BERI: See you.